Ryan Garcia I don't know if you follow
Ryan Garcia boxer he's coming up he is
part of Oscar De La Hoya scam that
always one of my investors and uh you
know Ryan Garcia had a fight a few weeks
ago and they showed this clip I hope we
have it that it's next to each other on
how he's training and he's practicing
this punch over and over and then when
it comes into real life if you have it
press it I want him to want to see this
okay if you if you notice this one here
so they're fighting okay do you have the
other one or no so he throws a punch
Oh gone right can you go back to it
again I mean do it again go back one
more time so he's about to fonseca's
throwing a punch how fast do you have to
be to have the instincts to respond to
that as a guy who's taking the punch
no no I'm talking Ryan Garcia when you
watch this his eyes are not twitching
look at his eyes his eyes are still open
he's not like closing his eyes and
throwing a punch he knows exactly what
he's doing you can tell this guy's
trained this and thrown this punch
20,000 times to know exactly what to do
but I'm what I'm wondering how much of
this is speed how much of it is instinct
you know pancha gotten you laid and a
coupon to hug each other
Gary sure got to sanctimonious Connery
tempo didn't go yeah so before this
attack happened this connection happened
what Brian Garcia was able to do is
figure out the opponent's happens so you
know some people would say what is it
their God their God we say so when the
opponent is jabbing his guard is luring
so my son gave an attack coming with you
so he rang her say essentially kind of
trick the opponent he he basically
didn't show any sign that he recognized
his that's crazy right there see what I
did they don't gotta go to paga
hugging a wall not in Korea tokiko
castle castle come on give me something
good
so what happened is that Ryan Garcia was
just waiting for this to happen so he
recognized this habit that the opponent
had which is know
and he just wait for the right moment
and the right distance to deliver that
blow Kutaragi I pay you keep them with
it so come get something good mmm so
it's not just you know the momentary
instinct or speed but it that was
planned out is what he was that was
plenty she was hungry pennant want to
reach a state election in Canada one you
look at or Chile's gonna it's an opening
opening it's a you know crucial habit
that he was able to pick out from his
opponent but he didn't you know he
didn't show any sign that he knew that
so he just waited waited and planned
this blowout that's that's pretty
interesting
what do you want do you follow boxing
and MMA or do you watch it yes I watch
you watch MMA and who do you like in
boxing who do you like in MMA maybe the
hug or maybe I don't candy - I hope you
know so he loves for Mayweather and
don't make really just jr. Roy Jones jr.
I was on a flight with them two weeks
ago interesting why Mayweather why Roy
join you this hang is a Jeff what I'll
go straight to DA go both pushing rest
air we're go for the box Eunice TACE
hold on does the current day Coderre
boxing which are you to tell me so the
common misconception when you think
about boxing is that you you're just
using your arms but when you see
Mayweather Roy Jones they utilize their
entire body and that's what's attractive
tone
you